i know it's crazy four movies seven
years cgi innovation at its finest today
we are taking a look at the avengers
movies and all the behind-the-scenes
magic that went into making them look so
good
number one
one small step for man a giant leap for
the green monster in the first avengers
movie way back in 2012 this green boy
was taking giant leaps forward with cgi
innovation
and i'm a huge fan of the way you lose
control and turn into an enormous green
rage monster before the avengers the
hulk had just been a cgi creature but
with the development of the form they
are building every expression off of
mark ruffalo for their first go-round
with the motion capture and the facial
capture mark had to do these two things
separately number two we love this
advancement almost as much as black
widow does
he has a temper
deep down he's all fluff for age of
ultron they wanted to take the hulk to
the next level with the photo realism
with the love story between him and
black widow really taking form the
ability to be in tune with both body and
facial expression became super important
luckily they had this ability for the
2015 blockbuster he's also a huge dork
chicks did that
number three the smartest hulk design
yet i put the brains and the brawn
together and now look at me they took
the photo realism a million steps
further by the time endgame came around
and you can tell the smart hulk is smart
due to the cardigans when i had the
gaunt with the stones i really tried to
bring her back in the case of smart hulk
it was important that the actor really
be in the scenes and not just in a
separate room recording the voiceover as
was the case for rocket raccoon number
four and speaking of the rabbit
rocket's design for the avengers movies
was easy because it was stolen straight
from the guardians movies other than the
new outfit of course ain't nothing like
me except me they used two actors one
for the voice over and one for the
motion capture there was no reason to do
mo cap on bradley cooper because the
difference between raccoons and humans
is pretty apparent but they did film him
while he was reading the lines to get a
general sense of the character i live
for the simple things
like how much this is gonna hurt sean
gunn also curls up to three feet tall to
play the physical character it's a
pretty awkward height to be at if you
ask us
number five iron man without reflective
armor would just be mad man technology
in the film world was evolving as tony's
tech did for the first iron man john
favreau wasn't confident they could
digitally create a full iron man suit so
they chose the practical method of
building it but that was quickly phased
out in later movies one of the struggles
they had in avengers was when the metal
suit came in contact with thor's wrath
or rather the blue lightning which
really messed with the color tones they
were going for in the suit the surfaces
of the suit were very finicky and so new
technology was developed to work with
different wavelengths of light
number six turns out animators are as
genius as tony stark by the time the
animators got to the nanotech everything
had changed nanotech requires multiple
layers of simulations including a liquid
metal simulation where iron man's suit
would morph into these weapons fluidly
where'd that come from it's nanotech you
like it one problem they had was that
the clothing was too textured and bulky
so it was rdj's idea to have the clothes
flattened to his body first
and by the time they got to endgame they
had perfected the suit however when the
suit appeared in spider-man far from
home they returned to their more rigid
suit design from captain america civil
war and quite literally destroyed it to
create this creepy scene number seven
mark ruffalo was not only thrilled to
work with james spader but also to teach
him the ways of the suit i'm trying to
explain to him you know how it all
worked filming with ultron proved to be
quite tricky for some of the noob
avengers including elizabeth olsen who
just couldn't get used to looking at the
red dots atop the actor's head that were
meant to represent ultron's eyes
probably the majority of the shots erin
i are both going like this
number eight the avengers fighting the
air is only slightly more embarrassing
than that one guy who waged war on
poseidon by now you might be thinking
wow she's only talked about the suits
and not the scenes yeah that's because
most of them are shot on boring boring
boring green screens but we've got a
cool scene to share now so good for you
for listening this far and here it is
yep that's your favorite avengers
fighting the air what an experience
aren't you glad you stuck around
number nine when you've got an avengers
level budget you can just build an
actual tower
joss wanted the entire set of the
avengers tower to be connected he wanted
scenes to be able to move from floor to
floor hence fun moments like the camera
operator in an elevator chair where can
we get one of those
asking for a friend
number 10. how many sub-ultrons does it
take to screw in a light bulb got a
punchline leave it in the comments
thor's cape wasn't even real in this
scene we wonder if edna mode had
something to do with it knuckles
remember how earlier we were talking
about the evolution of iron man suit
well the flexibility and creativity in
iron man 3 is what gave them the
confidence to have a whole army of
sub-ultrons imagine if they'd tried
doing age of ultron way back in 2008
number 11. the avengers assembling was
not as
assembly as it may seem building a scene
like this with so many moving parts is
partially trickery of the eye all of it
was shot against green screens this gave
the filmmakers more flexibility if beats
didn't cut together as well as they'd
hoped it was easier to move them to
somewhere that did you could say this
scene required a lot of assembling
number 12 performing magic spells
without the magic of cgi to accompany
you on set must be lonely it's kind of
the most boring of fight choreography
wait does it even count as fight choreo
or
more like dance choreo but the ability
to actually kind of fly on set is cool
at least number 13. we are about to hit
you in the feels pov you're seven years
old your teeth are brushed and you've
got your jammies on it is time for bed
and as per the bedtime ritual you give
dad a hug before climbing up the stairs
we warned you number 14. one of the
earlier designs of thanos looked just
like barney the dinosaur kidding maybe
eye lines are super important for an
authentic performance just like we
talked about with ultron when you've got
giant characters that gets complicated
instead of red glowing lights above the
head thanos head was on a pole in a
backpack they also added displacement
suits in areas where
other actors are interacting with the
character so that their hands are
landing in the right place
number 15 this isn't the first time
we've seen chris's face superimposed on
another body they cast an old guy with
similar features to chris evans to play
his skin double he tried to emulate
chris's performance as much as possible
to try and make it easier on the cgi
artists number 16 the best version of
thor needed no work all those hours at
the gym were wasted thor's body suit was
done practically but that doesn't mean
it's without its flaws they had to touch
up the seam in the back and also some
extra unrealistic rolls oh and say hello
to mocap porg but we don't think that's
taika ytt sitting there
number 17 they ran out of time to design
the time suits this time we aren't
joking seriously the time suits were a
combination of ant-man tony stark and
guardian's tech
due to the final movies filming back to
back they ran out of time to design them
before filming took place and said
whatever we'll figure it out in post
meaning the suits were fully cgi they
almost had ugly bubble helmets for a bit
we're glad they rethought that number
18. no mocap was required just two
chris's
the whole scene was cgi except the
chris's and even then it's impossible to
have two chris evans acted both parts
alongside a body double for the most
part they didn't have to do facial
replacements but they did a little bit
number 19. that feel when you start
filming and you have no idea if your
costume is comfortable
thank cgi for saving the day captain
marvel's suit was fully digital because
once again the designs for the suits
were not ready for initial filming
number 20. like getting ready for a
first date the crew tried a million
things to find that perfect blip the
blip took months of development they
wanted it to be quiet and elegant a
little bit of pain was mixed in but they
really wanted the pain to be felt by the
audience
well we felt it we sure felt it all
right
number 21 a silent but deadly joke seems
important to the context of this next
one
iron man it took time to find the right
tone of the tendrils as the infinity
stones
were eating away at the suit and the
suit was fighting to protect tony
number 22 we included this next one to
show you guys the awesome green screen
obviously
they should have called bruce banner
quicksilver did you see how fast that
guy ran
number 23 and did you see how magical
this blue screen is wow
and we are all better for it
did you hear that thump we think he hit
the boom mic and we are all the better
for it
yes yes we are number 24. the design is
quick and it's silver we say they nailed
it quicksilver's design was
intentionally not trying to play up the
effects they looked up various blurs and
trails and landed on the blue streak
trail and they included just a few
stills at a time of the actor so he
isn't completely a blur if you look
close
number 25 scarlett's design is well
scarlet and kinda witchy they nailed it
too you see pictures of scarlet witch
and she's always like that isn't that
spider-man's thing scarlett's power has
a similar design to her brothers don't
you think
that just happened it's actually
incredible just how much cgi has evolved
even throughout the course of these
movies from mark ruffalo's first time
doing mocap to his last and captain
america aging a hundred years it's
pretty freaking mind-blowing to remember
just how clunky cgi was a couple decades
ago are you impressed by the way cgi has
evolved let us know in the comments and
thanks for hanging out with us here at
the things